well the midterm elections they're next
week a week from Tuesday observers
campaigns candidates all try to get
clear insight into how exactly people
will vote but polls
consult as John langler explains a
Denver company though has a better idea
the Google searches should reflect a
candidate's entire efforts over their
lifetime their entire brand awareness
and the way in which voters perceive
that Skyler white is CEO of Denver's
Unum AI his company uses publicly
available Google Trend data to capture
political interests of every race in the
nation but there's nothing personally
identifiable it's just a way to
understand how people not any one person
are behaving it highlights which
candidates are getting the most
attention online white says the more
searches a candidate gets the better
they'll do and it seems to work in the
2020 election cycle we predicted uh all
U.S Senate races throughout the country
that had polling available twice as
accurately we were off by less than a
percentage point for every single
candidate so what does White's research
say about Nevada on Friday Unum AI
produced this look at this edit and
gubernatorial races here term you can
see here incumbent Democratic senator
Catherine Cortez masto started in the
lead fell behind to Republican
Challenger Adam laxalt in September but
has closed the Gap again it's still very
close incumbent Governor Steve sisalak's
lead in April is now gone Republican Joe
Lombardo now has a small lead that's way
more accessible and way more socially
acceptable to research online
than to
tell someone you don't know who's
calling to ask you if you believe in
conspiracies traditional pollsters are a
little skeptical after all how do you
know if the person Google searching is a
registered voter or even old enough to
take part still it's information they're
already using in campaigns in eight days
we'll see how close Google gets John
langler 8 News Now